foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's up stream I'm back sorry was uh
putting away the pyrene into the fridge
that's the truth I'm sticking to it
um all right so we're back I'm gonna do
probably another
like three to four hours probably not
that much I want to get another night
and get another morning
drinking some kombucha
um all right so I uh while I was away
I had I had like some thoughts
I thought about
um
the game of course uh
and I have some ideas
um as to what direction we're gonna take
it we let's headshot to Tim as well he's
going to
take the art in a slightly different
direction as well so we're going for
something a little bit more voxely
um then we first Maybe
set like landed on and uh
the the main kind of well the the gist
of it of course like is basically the
same as what we talked about in the
planning uh kind of time the planning
session that we had and that was
basically uh you're delivering coffee to
someone and it's in a war zone and I
guess you're delivering coffee to your
general or whatever and so the idea is
you're running around with this coffee
and you have to uh also fight off of
course the enemies who are attacking you
and that's hard to do with coffee
because you're hot you're literally
holding like a cup of coffee
and
so if you shoot like it's not going to
be that effective it's going to be kind
of like not very accurate and imagine
having like a sniper rifle and then a
cup of coffee and you can't put the
coffee down
um well at least you choose not to put
the coffee down so it's kind of like
you're sniping them and it's not doing
much but but wait you can put the coffee
down
and if you put the copy down yeah you
can actually properly like aim and shoot
your gun but the coffee is vulnerable
and you have to uh make sure
that you don't
um
you know lose the copy and the enemies
will be like screw this guy with a gun
I'm gonna go for the coffee because they
want they want the coffee as well
everyone wants the coffee it's basically
the scam
um
and so
that's the game
and I have a few kind of ideas of how I
want the mechanics of it to go so the
first thing we're going to do though
is we're basically going to pull down
the code the PETA
has pushed I believe so he added
uh basically a controller camera
controller and this is a new scene
called player controller testing which
we don't have to use that scene we might
not because I'm kind of working on level
generation but it would be good to
obviously see kind of what he's done so
let's pull this it's hopefully it'll
automatically merge the asset registry
and looks like it has
um so if we run this and there's going
to be quite a lot of engine well not
quite a lot but
there's going to be quite a lot of like
there's going to be a decent amount of
engine modifications that I want to have
to do namely uh just like simple stuff
like I don't want every object to be
rendered with the edge outline so we're
gonna have to have like an exclusion
list or something for objects that don't
go through that like particles for
example then I also want Shadows not to
be cast for certain meshes which we
should theoretically support but I have
a feeling that doesn't quite work
um so like for example I don't want the
particles to cause Shadows I don't want
the gun the the gun model that the
player is holding to cast Shadows so
I've got to have to exclude that what do
you like to eat the premiere with
um I honestly like a bunch of stuff and
I don't necessarily do them all at once
but I like some diversity so I have so I
have some butter
they pretty much usually bought it up so
they didn't stick together anyway uh and
then I like some sour cream some
smithana uh but then alternatively
I also like some soy sauce because it's
almost like dumplings kind of like
Chinese dumplings so I have some soy
sauce usually in a separate place or
something I can just pour a little bit
on when I feel like it and then Smith on
that Smitha and I usually don't or sour
cream I don't usually spread over all of
them so that's my detailed Strat for
Peter menu
all right
so let's take a look at Peterson
because I have not seen it yet I've seen
it a little bit on the stream on his
stream
but other than that I'm fine
that get thing is Fork
how comes you know Russian because I am
Russian moldovian my
my parents my dad's from Russia my mom
is from October I was born in Australia
but they brought me up speaking Russian
and I still kind of speak Russian with
them and with a bunch of with my wife's
family as well because the Ukrainian
so yeah all right
that's bright
that's probably just because of the
skylight
oh I need to compile the script it's my
bad
oh he probably added stuff to the script
as well didn't he
oh I need an engine pull
I do yeah thanks for reminding me all
right so I need to pull
uh engine as well
I don't think there's like a lot it was
just uh something in yeah in the actual
scripting engine that was changed
fixes uh all right
now what I want to do uh that I did yes
I need to build this but I also need to
generate
this right so I need to call that
should reload no need I need to compile
this
and let's launch it
what do you enjoy more opinion ah
funnily enough we had both today I went
to the supermarket and I bought like
both like I guess about anything which I
basically like that little dumplings
with potato and onion
and then also uh uh like Peter Mania
which are a bit smaller and they have
beef and pork
so and then we mixed I boiled a pot of a
big pot of water like this big
dumped them both in there and we have
some leftovers which is nice but
we actually had both pigmentium so
it's funny
why not stream on Twitch uh I kind of
like YouTube to be honest I mean apart
from the fact that most of my audience
is here it's just really nice because
um you guys can rewind the stream this
stream is better quality you can stream
at a higher quality than you can on
Twitch twitch which is limited limited
to six megabits per second which kind of
sucks I'm streaming at 10 at the moment
and actually Tim's also in the same
office streaming at 10 as well actually
I don't know what quality temp streaming
yet but anyway
yeah 10 10 megabits just seems to be
fast enough so I'm on like a good
quality off but six leaves a little bit
to be desired um
what else is good about this uh the
streams stay off obviously it's like an
immediate VOD that doesn't disappear
after 60 days so yeah just lots of
benefits kind of
I don't really see the benefit of twitch
too much to be honest
all right
so what was I doing
um yeah let's open Peterson
nah I'm the stupid skylight
Okay cool so you can move around
oh you can rotate the camera like this
oh so you can't rotate with the mouse
then
okay well we'll make it so they can
maybe but
yeah and that player is way too small
or is that just a one by one Cube
I guess it is
super kind of small
all right so let's see how we set it up
so he has a camera rig uh with a camera
rotator
that's checked and then he has like just
a normal camera on it and then that
follows the player and then the player
entity is set and that's kind of it oh
but there is a player controller here
and there's a camera rig as well okay so
let me quickly just jot this down and
I'm gonna try and recreate this in my
scene
I just want these same parameters
basically
so that's on the camera rig
[Music]
okay and camera camera and then player
Oh okay that's actually oh that is a
queue what's this then oh he just made
another Cube here that's fine okay
so this is my scene for those who
haven't seen it
which is uh
a little bit different looking
um so
uh
uh let's call this player two and we'll
make another so he basically he had a
player entity
um which actually let's duplicate
polyester
we'll get rid of the camera call it
player
um Q blah blah player two or just maybe
move off into the distance
um so this is player with Cube now he
had a script on it which was
this has no script script on it which
was player controller
uh camera rig we need to set up so he
had I think camera rig and then a camera
underneath that
um I don't think the camera really had
anything but this had a script
which was the player um no camera
Rotator all right camera Rotator
um
uh follows player player is
player
rotation length time 0.5 that's correct
and what else did he have a camera rig
is camera rig and
one 2.5 all right that actually should
be it let's just hit play
um
okay that's not oh we still have player
two's camera which I'll uncheck from
Maine for now
okay that does not look oh he probably
had let me just save this he probably
had a minus 45 degrees 60 60. I'll copy
that
[Music]
okay so that is very small though
why is it like floating
it's kind of cool actually
but why
it seems very far was it really that far
in his example not really
[Music]
by a scale is one camera rig scale is
one then why is that so far
is there a distance from player in one
of these Scripts
no hmm
I wonder why that's the case then I mean
it makes sense why it's firing us like
it's just the camera must be um
you know
you can just do this but it's just weird
that yeah because that was like 60
meters like this is probably a little
bit better but also why why are you not
on the ground
oh look it's falling why is there smart
[Music]
look it's just falling extremely slowly
these are the colitis
I still have my weirdo
script on it possibly
maybe not not in there I think it's just
because I didn't copy let's go back to
flag protesting I think I just didn't
have I didn't really copy this maybe
player
but no but that doesn't have that
doesn't even have a rigid body on it
oh maybe the fact that that does is what
screws it up
this player right
yeah let's get rid of the rigid body
yeah there you go
okay so that's still far so what did we
say was good like 10.
10 by 10.
I did those changes in play mode that's
why they didn't stay right okay we are
still not on the ground though bro
you know yeah this guy's not on the
ground
um oh that might be my fault oh that
probably is my fault it's just because
this is in the air
um
it probably needs to be
at one or something
oh yeah but that's you're not gonna
change the size yeah yeah
because I made the size specifically
yeah yeah the Height's fine as long as
you keep the ocean fine
yes please
it's like 1.5
I don't really know why but sure
yeah that's on the ground
okay so now we have this guy and you can
rotate the camera which
which is cool and it will follow so if
the mouse rotated the camera I guess
that would be nice
uh and then also Peter I think what
Peter did was he basically took
this player
and he added a little Cube uh at like a
little bit of an offset just to make it
look like it was like a visor but just
so you could see basically which way
you'd go so I kind of like the idea of
that I might replicate that
actually don't know if that's the right
way no it's not
okay there you go so now I can tell
which way it's going
uncle
I could even take that a bit further if
you wanted to
to make a little arrow
scented that
more things to waste time on
but whatever
probably change the color of that let's
just make it be like
red or something
I'll look like a multi-select
but you guys didn't see that coming
that's the first time I've used
multi-selection like
well basically look I had this and I
wanted to make all like they were just
the same they were gray and I'm like let
me just select all three and assign a
material to all of them yeah
so nice that's really cool because I'm
used to just not doing it really yeah
like I I kind of miss it
so we got the guy he's going around
uh
so that's cool
um all right
anyway that was a bit useless but I
still wanted to do it uh
we should
yeah so what I kind of wanted to do was
I think it's important for us to start
working on the mounts basically
um because my idea was we need to be
able to shoot right and to be able to
shoot I want to be able to click and
it's going to shoot in the direction
that I'm aiming in so it's a little bit
difficult at the moment because it's
kind of like I guess I want to be able
to rotate with the mouse just by like
yeah
um
and I guess what I want to also do
though is because it's going to be
really hard to aim obviously just
without anything I actually want to draw
like a debug I just want to draw like a
line that is kind of like the
you know it that's like the equivalent
of a Crosshair because this isn't in
like first or third person so whatever
way you point you'll get like a line
um it might be like a little fans if
it's a sniper rifle it might be really
really long if it's like a shotgun it
might be several lines up close I don't
know or maybe just like three lines or
something cool
like that and then as you shoot the line
will probably animate a little bit and
it will probably also because shooting
is probably just going to be a raycast
so it will probably um
I wanted to also make it what I want to
make it do I wanted it to yeah so once
you fire a shot you see the accuracy of
it be like reflected in the line so like
if it's a low accurate like if it's not
an accurate weapon or whatever then when
you shoot it might like you know animate
like that or whatever showing which way
I guess the last shot went
um to give you an idea of how it's
working so that's kind of the idea I had
um so to do that that should be
relatively easy I think
like I should basically just be able to
let's bring this up let's uh probably
get rid of that
and this
um
and I'm gonna just dock that in let's
get rid of that
[Music]
so
um
foreign
controller is what's on the player right
yeah
yeah okay so the first thing we I kind
of wanted to do was in update uh let's
do a draw Crosshair
and draw price here like croissant
funny
so this is going to use the debug one
renderer to be completely honest uh
let's draw a line
uh let's start at our translation let's
go
uh translation plus rotation
no that's not quite work is it I need to
get the full Direction
how do I do that forward Direction
no I think it's um
uh I think actually no I think it's just
transform dot forward no
uh I guess try and get um
component trap it might be this
our API needs a little bit of work
how do I get the forward
oh doc transform.worldtransform.forward
okay
make it like 10 meters
and you want a color so let's make it
like
new vector or one zero zero and then
we'll do like point seven or something
so I'll make it a little bit
not quite fully opaque
um crashed all right this is actually
funny because I yes okay I have not like
this is my new renderer and I actually
just realized I did not test debugger
rendering so it doesn't surprise me if
this doesn't work so let's see what
happens so Pipeline and we'll have to do
some graphic debugging now hopefully
this isn't a long fix though uh you just
said zero but that set is not bound does
it really use that zero it shouldn't use
set zero wait that's a text
render 3D text that should not be trying
to write a text
oh this text and that texture text works
um but I I suspect I was just like some
kind of
I think a lot I just haven't had no no
hang on well first of all line rendering
definitely works though because we use
we use that for the physics collider
debug so that at least Works
um
so I don't know why that didn't work
we might have to actually debug that I
probably should just debug them
but render 2D text using set zero like
Is that real life
because it shouldn't be
are the font Alexis no well that makes
sense yeah but it shouldn't be using R
you know what you know what it is it's
probably
no that doesn't make sense because it
wouldn't have washed farther places I
have a feeling it's trying to randomize
using the text Trader Maybe
which is a bit weird aha text pass I was
right
fix hopefully
but how does that work because we use
that not just for runtime line rendering
we should have used that for like the
physics gliders for example like the Box
colliders for under the visualization
for them so it's very strange that it
seems to have
Mike worked for that but then wrote for
this
okay well that worked so you can see my
line my line works
pretty dope
um
and then yeah I can make that like
shorter
so this is like you can see this is just
two
meters
from the origin which is here of the uh
let's see
so
yeah I like the music
um it's making me work quickly which is
good
uh okay so I have my Crosshair that was
very easy I didn't really expect it to
not be easy but
there's my Crosshair let's keep it at a
distance of four for now
now of course I don't want it to just
move in one of eight directions like
this I actually want it to be smooth so
we're gonna have to damn Peter if we put
together some uh Coral I guess from
different from other projects to support
controller support disable controllers
which is good
all right so let's see
um I want to basically we'll leave this
as is uh for now what I want to do is
the camera yeah the camera which is
um going to be based on
the
so how's Peter put this together
rotation direction zero plus equals up
plus get horizontal rotation
in which
d-pad or analog stick but that's like
oh but also rotation direction minus
equals yeah so we probably just need to
keep track of the mouse
[Music]
I'm guessing
uh
I should probably lock the mouse as well
and then maybe if we hit Escape
but read my mind uh let's do input dot
uh is
sorry input set cursor mode
so we have a way to unlock it
um
[Music]
so if get cursor mode if that's
let's just say if that's
normal
and we click
string in there
now we click the left Mouse button
then we want to lock it again
okay so there's some Mouse stuff
um
have lost Mouse position
so
Anywhere But Here
okay so that should be fine and then the
mouse Delta which
[Music]
uh no I'm just thinking that it might be
too much
now this is like three
of them as well uh uh did I I close that
file
uh why would I thought I used lore over
so sharp C sharp is a much better
language for serious stuff
um all right
so this is probably just like why right
well this is going to be up times that
so I guess we can just do that
uh Mouse Delta X right
okay well that's done it's just very
sensitive that's predictive uh should we
do a times time step for that
yes like my guess right because
otherwise if we don't then like it's
going to do that more often
yeah there you go so we can rotate it it
doesn't rotate the player but you can
see I can rotate it and my mouse is
locked so I can just keep doing that
which is good so that was pretty quick
still does it if it's locked so
um
let's do a private void Mouse rotation
passing Delta time
reason why I'm doing this is because
uh
is because
okay we're doing a rotation direction
and we eventually do that that's okay I
can just do
let's make this ba of vector three
and then for now we'll just do
like that I guess so we won't rotate
with the arrow keys anymore let me just
make sure that that works yep and then
I'll just do uh we can yeah we can
probably still do that
well this might just be the cursor but I
guess if um the idea is if
this
doesn't equal locked
I was going to return
or attempt zero
so that we basically only rotate when
it's locked out we'll just make it a
little bit better for basically
debugging I don't know it doesn't really
need to be better in the game but yeah
all right
Louis is a fine language like I don't
want to say it's a bad language I'm not
saying it's a bad language but it is a
bad language for like building a pink
game
it's good for like it's a good scripting
language but like the thing is it's not
a full-on programming language like C
sharp like you can't compare C sharp and
lower like it's you know it's crazy
about like it's a it's a fine language
and it's very very fast and it's
lightweight and it's very easy to like
obviously just run in a in a box like
environment and stuff it's great but
it's not like good for full-on games
all right
uh so
um what should we do now
foreign
yes I want to get onto that
um it's just this is like my third time
or fourth time streaming on YouTube
since I kind of came back to streaming
on YouTube so I haven't really had time
to set that up but with that yeah I will
do that all right
uh sorry
I guess I'd like to
get the player to face that direction
now
right because that way we could
basically Aim so
um we should probably just
because the player at the moment will
kind of set
his own Direction like this look
Direction gets set and update facing
Direction which Peter spent a little bit
of time on unfortunately
so that just does set rotation and it
looks at a particular direction
so we could kind of do that
uh
so
if we do this basically
does that is that just gonna make that
work
very close
he's just like a little bit in the
ground for some reason
it's a bit weird isn't it oh because the
camera no no
it's because the camera's on an angle
that makes sense yeah so well the thing
is I don't know if we necessarily need
this like to do it through cottonians
and stuff because
we could obviously still do it that way
but
like at the end of the day
it's kind of just like how can't we just
do
rotation
I'm just gonna try something
can't we just take the
just the Y
from that
yeah we definitely can oh
no okay that's being all glitchy I think
oh maybe we can't actually maybe I
should use set that to avoid gimbal
locks and stuff but um I just need to
not actually do this as well
probably
yeah see that's annoying because it will
possibly not work at times and that's
wrong anyway right
or is that just an exact mirror
because the the thing is like the player
his why at the moment why rotation yeah
it's a gimbal it's a gimbal Orchestra as
well
um all right
probably not a big deal but
let's still do it this way I think but
what I can do
yeah what if I yeah
what if I just did this
uh that is much for us
so bad
oh well
I think I maybe try to do that the thing
is Peter also has some
card on the rotation
like on the thing which maybe screws it
up a bit that's definitely not right
maybe I'm not trying to do that though
maybe that was being weird because it
was in there I doubt it though
where's the camera so the camera rigs
the thing that's moving all right
and it's just the white oh but look the
camera rigged
actually the rotation of the camera rig
is always it's just it is just wide
because the camera is on an is out of
405 degree angle angle not the rig
so in that case and the camera rotators
on the camera I guess so then why did
that not work
like I should just be able to basically
do that like full-on
don't even need this or whatever so
that's really strange but that's not
working okay so now it is yeah that's
fine that's set
I I would still definitely uh make the
camera not quite be that so if this is
the player's rotation that's fine but
the camera's rotation should be
different
um
and it is actually supposed to do
something like this I don't know if it
is lurping is actually correct
I have a feeling of my uh that that
actually doesn't look bad
plus Delta time times 0.5
rotation Target rotation so then
but that doesn't look like that does it
that looks like it kind of snaps
instantly
because I wanted to make it a bit
delayed the rotation of the camera
um
but it looks like it looks like this
happening way too quickly
so let me just log that maybe
it's a zero all the time what
is this always true
does this ever happen
no
what
rotation dot equals up so the rotation
is always set to that
pow
or is it because this is such a small
number
for Epsilon but that's no it can't be
that small
what
so why is this always true
because look I've incremented that by
something
huh
maybe let player rotations to the camera
yeah that's a good uh
should probably do that as well actually
[Music]
um
I mean that would work the same way like
because then I could do the same thing
here
so we could do an easy and out for
example from current rotation
to Target rotation as well like that
but the thing is again that's never
running because rotation is always equal
to Target or attention basically how
though
how is this always true
wait can I debug I can can I
um
okay to promise me this will work so
yeah it is working okay
um
yeah but that doesn't like
that's obviously it's not rotating at
the moment it's gonna be hard so I don't
think debugging is a good
idea because I don't think it's gonna
oh wait oh yeah so now it's not rotating
player but that's again that's because
uh they're equal
[Music]
bro what's up
I don't know why these two are equal
considering I'm obviously incrementing
it again unless this is just such a
small thing
it's not though it's like up to it goes
up to like one
what the heck
how is this always true
there's got to be a bug in this code or
something
what does this do so x equals x if
if x is greater than or equal to other
dot x minus Epsilon
bro they're all the same you
ah
Peter
[Music]
say Tim
come look at Peters equals Epsilon code
takes in a vector three
checks to see if the x is equal if the Y
is equal and if the Z is equal and if
they're all equal it returns true
because you're kind of comparing see any
problems with this code
where's this actually oh it's always
yeah
amazing
so the reason the reason why that was
working before is because the x-axis
wasn't the one being changed it's the
rotation rotates the Y and because the x
is obviously always equal it was
returned true
so that's uh I'm gonna need you guys to
shame Peter a little bit when he comes
back because that is just like that is a
another
that's a rookie error
like I don't
remember how many years ago it was when
I did something as blatant as that
that's like
get caught that in Primary School
[Music]
over working
hey okay so now this is garbage but at
least it
works fine
um
[Music]
so now this code will actually probably
run so let's see what Peter's camera was
supposed to look like
yeah so this I guess is a bit smoother
Maybe still kind of doesn't
okay well we're definitely in this
Branch now because it's printing stuff
oh actually is it
yeah we're definitely in there now
because it's been it's been printed
um now this is probably a little bit
wait divided by 0.5 so it's actually
making it faster let's make it slower I
think it's too fast
yeah so there you go now you get your
little like this is way too laggy uh but
that's also not really correct
uh we are we basically kind of do like I
don't know where Tim finished up on that
but he was adding tests for math so we
did want to do that I just don't think
it's done yet that's all
that's all but yes it's important
um all right
so so let's see so that's obviously not
like I definitely don't want to do that
um I also think that like
I don't know if this should be reset to
0.5 necessarily I feel like
you want to almost start at 0.5 because
you want it to like snap I guess
immediately and then it probably should
just be like an ease out not an easy and
out
that'll probably feel better that might
be too quick
maybe if I because I started at 0.5
oh no no hang on sorry uh oh no that is
what I wanted to do
right
well that just feels normal actually
I don't know why
why ah because it the reason why is
because if you keep moving the camera it
doesn't reset
it only resets if you completely stop so
that's a little bit annoying to be
honest
because it doesn't reset the reset the
timer which means if you keep moving it
a little bit the way Peter's written it
is if you keep moving it a little bit
it'll it won't do the animation so I
don't really think that this should
necessarily happen I think it's kind of
like every time you move the camera if
it's not zero it probably should just
reset this maybe but that will also make
it jump
right
[Music]
so like this is almost like when it
might be nice to just set like a even
though that's not a good way to do it
you could kind of set a
a Target here
[Music]
it's a bit weird isn't it
so it's always going to be halfway
between these but that doesn't feel like
it's doing what it says it's doing
this is the lame way to do it
interpolations but
[Music]
it's just too quick
yeah I can
so this is called I call this the
asymptote blurp because what you're
doing is you're basically being like
uh instead of animating a graph from
zero to one which is kind of like how
you should use the interpolation
functions you're basically
being like you know what all the time if
this is like this is my B and then this
is like my a where I'm currently am I'm
always going to take you know 30 of it
so that means that you're going to be
like all right the first frame I'm
setting it to this so now the graph next
frame starts from here right so now
you're here then you take 30 of that and
so you jump up to here and so you can
see kind of what you're doing you're as
time goes on it's like you're getting
this is time
um you're getting like less and less
because you have 30 of like this now and
you'll never get there because it's an
asymptote basically but which sucks
because
you'll never reach it it's not really
correct so technically what I like to do
is not do that I like to just use
you know an actual animation of zero to
one
but the only downside is that if you do
always drag it the only upside of this
is that if you do always drag it along
like that it means that if you suddenly
change direction it's going to be smooth
and you don't have to do anything fancy
to get that to happen so I don't know
like if I'll realistically keep that but
because again if you want to see the
downside then you'll just see like if I
do log one rotation so if I actually
display the rotation actually you know
what why are we this logging thing is
it's fine but
let's actually use a text component
because that will just be a little bit
easier so if I just make a text
component
um
let's do like 90. or minus 90.
and
I'll drag it up a little bit put it
maybe behind the player
tail it down a little bit
and the reason why I've done this is
because now we can just
print debug stuff to that I could have
done it for the utility viewport as well
but it's kind of nice when it's on the
call this debug text
hey baby just please
all right whatever
yeah so if I just do uh
find and actually buy Tag
debug text or get component oh this is a
bit slower but it doesn't matter
text component dot text equals
uh string dot format
can we just do Vector three two string
rotation to string
oh semicolon
okay so you can see as I move this you
can see and it's not printing all the
decimal points but you can see I mean
that's not too bad but you can see how
long it takes to stop
that's not I guess that's not too bad
if you make it even
longer though I guess that'll take
longer I don't know I think that's quite
showing it
[Music]
and that's all right
too bad
um okay so now let's make it rotate with
the player
wait why is the player not rotating
[Music]
oh that's just the camera that's why
we could actually offset the player like
make the player a little bit so that's
the camera we can make the camera a bit
quicker and the player a bit slower
um
why
why don't you just be normal
isn't that weird that it's not normal
why is it rotating on yeah it's fighting
with the game like it's fighting with
like
converting it to a matrix or whatever I
wonder why though because like the
camera is not all right
so why is the camera fine with that
I'm just setting the rotation to that
that really shouldn't be doing what it's
doing
is it because this is like very slightly
like if I make this
0.01 or whatever
there's some weird
problem
yeah that's super weird because all I'm
doing is oh but I guess I'm not I'm not
quite incrementing it
hmm
rotation
strange it's just weird because it's
clearly working for the camera but not
for the player what if I just set like
play a rotation to rotation
I mean that definitely should work I
guess but it's weird because it just
looks like it's a conversion thing
but see that's what I didn't want to do
because now it's like not lagging behind
and also it's going the wrong way I
think
yeah that's better
you can actually see by the Crosshair by
like how I'm aiming you can kind of see
how it's going the wrong way
oh my part is not working
um
but I do wonder why this doesn't work
like why does that get all weird
and it starts fighting with the axes
so it's got to be doing some kind of
conversion I mean that's just like again
this is just a vect three
like what it looks like is it's
converting it to a matrix and then back
again
but I don't know why it would ever be
converting it back again
oh because it's a physics Brigid body
and
is it it's not
oh it gets a rigid body
yeah it gets a rigid body because it has
a box Collider
it's like an implicit rigid body and
apparently that means that it goes
through that process which basically
breaks it
so that really sucks
hmm
yeah it's because of the physics object
what if I might get a trigger
that's super annoying
but if it's a static rigid body
I mean in all seriousness that probably
shouldn't be a static rigid body
like I wonder if we make it a dynamic
razor body
so that's probably gonna make this not
work right
no it's not the movement still works
even if it is a dynamic rigid body
strangely enough
put on the on the entities layer
um
let's go through that for a second
I just want to see the movement of the
movement still fine
I wonder if we go through the effort of
getting the rigid body maybe components
can we set the rotation on that
like would that be better
no
yes because it's because it's doing a
conversion it's nothing to do with
quaternions here it's because it's doing
um
it's because it's converting the
XYZ rotation to a matrix and then back
again
and it doesn't know because there's
multiple Solutions
that's why
we should just handle that though if
there are multiple Solutions just go
with one consistently
if that's possible I'll go with like the
like for example the smaller one
maybe I should try that
like what does that
I think something physics transform
synchronized body transform
so translation from jolt vector and set
rotation from Italian so it might be
this as well
foreign
from a quaternion we'll do this
I guess that's why well it tells a
rotation as well but it does this
[Music]
laughs
foreign
this is strange though that this is
happening because
like again
say hi to those Pakistan please hello
why are you yelling at me though
foreign
I mean that would make it better but
that's not the reason why it's not
working uh because then I I would rather
come up with something else I'm not yeah
I don't know why to be completely honest
because this is what's up frame blade
um
I don't know why because we don't like
this isn't really
um
like it's in it is it does use
quaternions internally so I don't know
why it's acting like it doesn't
because it definitely is acting like it
doesn't right now
um
so I feel like there's maybe some part
in the code I mean that's gotta be the
synchronized body transform that we saw
though
right
like that's gotta be this
oh but look that's not Ah that's not
being called so it's not here
I thought it was this but are we calling
set rotation
bro we are not
are you serious
then what is doing that
I may have found a bug
um
[Music]
that's great glue
something something rotation
cloudy 2D
there's reciprocation
get rigid body access set rotation
we're turning oh well that I guess that
converts back to three oh that might be
why wait okay if that really is the case
then though
um
then why don't I just
yeah do what I was doing before maybe
and just do set rotation using a
quaternion and then I can just do
basically what Peter was doing
because maybe that will work
like if I set that just to just
let's get rid of this
but then I need to do like a slurp
probably
but whatever let's not interpolate it
yet let's just do
I just set it to Target rotation
sorry this is player set rotation
let's see that oh okay so that kind of
worked it's just that it's on an angle
now
um which yeah is super weird though the
reason like why is it on an angle
because
um
is this me because I'm sinking but also
I'm at 90 degrees x rotation
what
oh wait
but also I'm not actually rotating
player dot set rotation to Target
rotation and I'm not rotating should I
do forward maybe I need to do forward
no
right
that's very weird I mean I kind of like
up up seems reasonable but
it's not it's weird isn't it
um oh hold on
oh effective three forward and up so oh
but that's not forward is it that's my
up that's why
I think because I'm actually trying to
make no wait that doesn't make sense
either
what
what no up is always up and then that
but that I just don't know if that
necessarily represents
my forward Direction
because
what that is is zero one oh
yeah it's not really going to is it so
what I pay to do here yeah because
that's the look Direction
so where did he yeah and that actually
is a forward Direction
right but that's an angle so
if I did
um
so I kind of need to rotate
damn that's a bit annoying
so I need to basically take how do you
do that man I need to take the forward
vector
and I need to rotate it
by the rotation
so
you know
in a way it's like I need the rotation
Matrix and I can multiply it with it but
is there a simple way to do that it
sounds way more simpler than it really
should be
[Music]
I mean I can use trigford for it I guess
I think it's just um
uh
sign of
Target rotation y
zero for that obviously and then
cosine
toggle rotation dot y
I think that might be
correct
yep dunsies
God that was so difficult and absolutely
no reason
it's because I suck is why
um all right so
think I'm getting closer to a Tim Tam
as soon as I deserve one all right so
but in the good in in a in other news
Hazel hasn't really crashed he crashed
like once didn't it oh yeah because the
text rendering because I that was a bug
in the renderer
it took me luckily like a minute to fix
but yeah
okay
so let me so now we have this kind of
slightly laggy camera Let's uh
we have this kind of slightly laggy
camera
which is kind of cool
now the play I'm moving weirdly is
that's on Peter and I don't know why
we're sinking either
that's a bit weird
let's go to the player controller
honestly why are we sinking oh I I did
maybe I removed some stuff yeah because
I've got a dynamic rigid body now let's
get rid of that
so there we go now we're good now I yeah
it does seem like
see the debug rendering all that I don't
like the player pops like that though
why is a player doing that because not
just the line rendering that's weird
it's the um
you have done I
correctly that off and now
I guess the reason why is just because
of
maybe we should do a light update
function that can go because the problem
is you move the player and then you want
to set the camera lights
but I don't think we have that
no I mean there is a physics uh
which happens later isn't there
on physics update when does that happen
physics and pre-simulate
and where when does that happen
and jolt simulate
that's actually before on update okay
well if we could do
I mean technically if we could do
like if I change this to be
do this but
let's just see what happens if I do this
then I can't move anymore
that's upsetting
now I can move but it's not like the
camera
that seems weird isn't it
I don't like the way the camera
is
I also kind of think that there's not
enough tilt
45 degrees
focus should be like 60.
and maybe you can't see as well behind
you
5 10.
is that better
probably a little too close
six Maybe
I don't really like that I think it
worked a bit of similar
maybe 45 was fine
that's kind of a cool perspective
actually
just built a new PC to run Hazel that's
funny
and a little unfortunate
um
that like I said that it requires that
uh okay so
um yeah how do I get the camera to be
better
I mean I think it's because of the
update order
that's what I'm thinking
so like I don't know technically
speaking like we could introduce an
entirely new c-sharp function called
late update which I would like to have
which happens after all the other NT
updates so if you need to do something
right before rendering after physics has
been simulated and transforms have been
moved you can do that that might be
better
um
always
so that would happen like
[Music]
yeah so that's audio stuff uh
uh yeah so say we do on update here
so we could kind of do the same thing
but after that there is a post update
queue that submits things but that's
different
um yeah and then we could do a late
update or whatever after that after this
basically
that would probably fix it and probably
worth doing that
because otherwise like either that or we
control entity update order which isn't
great
but let me maybe add that to be honest
because I feel like we should have that
regardless and so it's probably nice to
have that
uh post object here
all right that should happen later
[Music]
it should really be as simple as that I
think
that actually should be it because if it
doesn't exist it doesn't call it a thing
doesn't have to exist oh but it will
anyway because I'm gonna add it to empty
so that actually might have just been it
I think that's as easy as it is to add a
custom
function
possibly
like I don't know
and I guess we can have a
um
little thing for it as well
so okay so the reason why I did this is
because now let's build that I can go
into my camera and be like so there's
like the camera needs to be set to
whatever the player ends up being right
before we render kind of
um and in in fact all of this should
probably be there
um so if we just change this to on late
update
that should uh probably work
call it post update I don't know
whatever
[Music]
oh it's finished No it didn't
well disk space available 3.3 gig
um but now it's back up to like 9 and 10
gig I guess compiling I should free some
stuff though
shouldn't I
yeah oh wait no that's still the same
problem
what
how
how slash y oh did I rebuild this I did
but we're doing it on Light update now
so it's definitely happening afterwards
oh but we're setting the pullet no we're
saying fire rotation
and if for his player which that's going
to be true it's setting the translation
to player translation here
so how's that possible then
that doesn't make any sense
what
that actually does not make any sense
I love that movement that's so weird
I don't know how Peter's made this
movement
let me read it a bit more because that
is super weird
well there's a Target translation oh
because it's doing some weird
interpolation stuff as well
uh
um
let's just not do this and let's instead
do
like what we kind of
did before
I don't know if we need to interpolate
the movement like that though
um
but yeah because that still kind of does
that
and that's still like you know it's like
it's still updating the camera somehow
before
so that doesn't make any sense
wait am I a buffoon
I am a buffoon
uh I knew I knew it
it's because I don't even know how this
works it shouldn't work probably because
this I only did this for the run time
this is not done for the editor
how do I
but then why did it even work
because it shouldn't have called my
camera code at all
so that's very suspicious
like this stuff in camera Rotator should
not have been called
but clearly it's being called
like how
that's very very weird
because we have a different function for
updating the editor
um
oh sorry on I guess it's wait what
or maybe I'm wrong
maybe I haven't befriended
I think this probably gets called by
on the other as well then right
where does this get called
oh that's yeah run time is in
yeah no that does luckily go through the
same function that's fine
so it is calling out obviously yeah
because otherwise it wouldn't be there
but how
um
but yeah there's no way that it's like
so if we do like
so we read the player translation here
right
so let's do camera translation equals
and let's do this in player as well this
is bizarre
not closed handle
I said pause so let's see what happens
here so
camera translation okay well I am
should have uh made this a player
transmission
so yeah the first one here is clearly
the player translation
and then the camera translation so the
order is correct as we've kind of
determined
um but what's weird is that
so let's move a little this is going to
be hard to
Hunty pog
so it doesn't make any sense
but no but actually it looks like the
camera is ahead of the player though
yeah the camera's ahead of the player
what
how can the camera be ahead of the
player
what
this is so strange
the player's translation just gets set
to this basically
which is pretty standard
that all comes from on update
so and that doesn't this doesn't matter
so
but what looks like is happening is I'm
moving and the player it take like the
camera for one frame is basically one
frame oh hello
hello Cube
the player is one frame
the the camera is one frame ahead of the
player
that's what's happening
but I just don't get how that would be
possible
because
like it gets submitted for rendering
later and
it doesn't yes in this case it doesn't
matter then
I guess well but either way the the
player's translation gets updated first
and then we tell the camera to set its
translation to the player's translation
so they should be equal
by the time it gets set to rendering by
the time it gets sent yeah to be rounded
but they're not
the camera sent how can the camera be
ahead of the player though I get the
player being ahead of the camera
but the camera being ahead of the player
[Music]
and I mean we're just setting like for
the camera it's not like we're doing any
weird interpolation stuff right
like we are just setting translation
equals player translation
oh
is it again because the player is a
physics object and maybe the translation
hasn't been Consolidated yet
but again it's it's the camera is
the one ahead
but let's just try this get component
rigid body component
it's got translation like what if we do
that
can make any difference no
yeah I know I should probably move on
but this is really bugging me
it kind of ruins everything
I feel like there should be some to be
honest there should be a little bit of
pitch
like it's just a touch
right because I think we're actually
storing
uh
uh that right
does it would it be hard to add a bit of
pitch
maybe maybe not
um
so what is this
so let's go back to three right times
this
so that maybe we'll just straight up
water
and now we can fly wonderful
um that kind of does work but I do want
to set a limit
so basically with this
no one
alone
I kind of want to make sure that
pictures
clamped between like
I don't even know what this trick is
I guess I guess I can just do that maybe
oh yeah
[Music]
because this is the Delta
I can't climb the Delta
um
[Music]
sometimes
clamp is uh we can let's go clamp for
Vector is Right surely ah or inspection
uh Target rotation between well the
thing is for is this the pitch that I
want to control it so maybe like between
minus 30 and minus
[Music]
60 or something
ah sorry what am I doing
um yeah that's between that and then
this we don't care about at all
[Music]
oh well then why am I doing the whole
thing to be honest um let's do
[Music]
thank you
I think that's what I want
yep that's what I want
um
I thought I was right but I think I am
where's the camera
foreign
[Music]
so positive 30 and positive 60 I guess
quiet not zero
ah because the camera is at an angle
I don't
the thing is pitch was never pitch was
just camera not camera rig
so maybe I should
keep it like that and and actually if we
look at it
uh
camera yeah it was minus 45.
and I guess like two
oh but no we can't because otherwise
[Music]
all right so let's do give and give or
take 15 degrees then
that'll probably be all right
so if I do that basically negative 15 to
positive 15
. I call that be better
why are you not clamping man
this plant not worked with negative
values
should yeah it's just this is that
what
ah is this in
yeah why is that not working
[Music]
oh it is
it's in um it's not in degrees
yeah I need to fix that but
I guess that's not bad
it's a bit annoying to have just this
level there isn't it
okay now keep the guy on the ground
though man
so he just goes
in look Direction so
but why
but he should never be going up
but what's look Direction four times oh
because it gets this that's why
can I just do this
no unfortunately
why can I not do that
uh because something uh because I'm
doing it in the wrong place
yeah there you go
I don't know if this is kind of more
frustrating or not though
because it's kind of like you're not
letting the player see
much at all
you can kind of have a bit more of a
top-down view but
I feel like it might be better just be
one angle rather than have this like a
little degree of freedom
that makes you frustrated
although maybe it's just because it's
not enough freedom but I don't want to
give too much freedom because then
we'll need entirely different rendering
strategy to make sure that we can render
The Horizon properly
but it would be kind of cool to have
that
also doesn't make the Sensitivity I mean
it's just too much at this point
where am I
camera I guess
where's my sensitivity
still pretty
pretty quick
too slow
like it'll be configurable but yeah
okay well I might leave it like this for
now just because I think it's kind of
cool but yeah we are gonna have to fix
this Blackness and yeah all right
okay so I did want to implement some
some sort of like shooting or whatever
and enemies so I guess we'll do that now
um yeah the iteration time of Hazel is
great like the fact that you can just
switch like from this do something
switch back no problem
like it's yeah that's one of the best
fishes for sure now my
um
I wish I could when I'm in this camera
be nice if it didn't move the player um
can I just
I can just do that or I can see if the
right Mouse button is clicked I might
remove that later but if the right Mouse
button is clicked maybe don't move the
player
[Music]
so now if I'm in uh
yeah so see it's not going to move the
player if I'm here
in this added a camera which if I well
it is if I just do that but if I hold
right Mouse button to move the camera
it's not going to move the play out so
it's nice because the best I get like
close and personal to it
but otherwise that's the game camera
okay
it's funny because this guy actually is
controlled by me as well this is the
original player off you go they're like
rocket League or something
um all right so
enemies and stuff
um
sure let's add that
let's duplicate the player
column enemy and we are good
uh
uh we'll change the script as well and
red Maybe
[Music]
uh
yeah I can make this
like orange or something
blue
so I can tell but this is what our enemy
will look like this is reminding me of
like among us or something to be honest
it's just missing the Dome
um
the capital thing uh we could make it my
capsule
or whatever we'll give them boxes for
now so
let's make a profile out of that right
enemies
all right done
so now enemies are pretty fab see
uh
yeah kind of sauce
um
so we should probably spawn them level
generator maybe I don't know
let's maybe make another interesting
calls on
to our enemy manager
let's
I might actually just copy this
okay
and now we are the script and the script
is enemy manager enemy is you Inc uh
okay so now we can spawn enemies uh they
don't do anything obviously
um private
at least
entity
active enemies
music where are you I was enjoying you
let's do more of you
uh what's up guys I'm not bad it'll be
busy but yeah
I'm making a game really quickly you
know like
take off quite deserve one here but I'm
on my way
um all right so active enemies uh let's
spawn in a bunch well actually we could
probably just like
next enemy climate
call it TS
if next enemy time on Less Than Zero
foreign
debugging uh spawn anime
I guess it'd be nice to get the players
location as well
because then we can kind of do it around
the player right
so we could be like uh translation
so the player's translation and if I
kind of just basically
equals
rather plus uh new Vector three and then
we'll just do a random
So within like 10 meters or within five
or five meter radius
uh same high same like location
same altitude
not so big just for you guys
uh instantiate enemy translation
right
I guess
you don't really look really yet
I mean I kind of wanna wait do I even
need anything oh well this is like I
said spawner Forum I don't know if I
need to necessarily add
this list because the thing is if they
get destroyed I'm gonna have to manage
that so I don't know we'll we'll see if
I actually need that because that way I
could recall all of them and order them
all to kind of block and do stuff but
like I don't know if that's necessary
we'll see
um
okay so at the moment we're just gonna
spawn enemies they don't really do much
let's copy and paste energy manager call
it and me
so now we have enemy
I don't know why it is
it must have renamed something else
okay that doesn't matter
fixed okay so enemy all right and he
already has that right that's fine
um I guess player would be good to have
and then we basically just need you
to Vector three
thanks
mikhailinoff for the donation
appreciate the support how's it going
going good uh got a nice game idea just
need to
get through all the work
um
and Tim by the way is making the art if
you guys go to Studio channel.com
uh you'll see all of our streams in one
on one page
um Peter's sleeping though at the moment
all right so let's see
[Music]
nothing else
I need a slab
um
what did I do for this guy though
but I guess I did want to slap because I
wanted it to kind of turn around but
let's just do the non-slapping version
first it's easier to see if it works um
let me just actually add the script
though because we need the script here
to be
I can't find it I already have script
and we do oh the enemies actually player
control that's funny uh enemy
and players
[Music]
wait do I see them yeah I really should
add these guys to a level
see because otherwise they're all just
here
no enemies don't seem to be spawning in
I don't see them here right what are
they supposed to be called Enemy enemy
manager why are you not odd players now
God there's a switch up exception yet
because players know so let's um set
player
for this guy
well I said I don't know where to spawn
I might spawn off the world or whatever
oh also they're not really physics
bodies at the moment are they
why
[Music]
oh
it's funny
adding code into an assert or something
that you actually want to happen
okay here they are
they're not uh
really
oh they are they have just I did it the
wrong way I had a feeling I took the
wrong way
so now they should all be scarily
looking at me
yeah they are
guys stop looking at me
you're freaking me out
um
okay so let's quickly slap them
[Music]
foreign
how do I do slurping in fragile
it's a way to get
oh it's probably
a set rotation on the trans
how do I get the rotation as I could
turn
it had to have done that surely
ah I want to see how I did slurping
fragile
[Music]
I never
ever
[Music]
because missiles did some slurping
oh you're just doing your equatorial
rotation okay yeah
so new quaternion
good thing I did that in that project to
get things
that rotation of that
a little bit more performance intensive
but
maybe better
[Music]
I mean that might be too quick
to see there's a little bit of a delay
now which is just cool
[Music]
if I do that
I mean it's still kind of quick but
a little bit more lifelike
now I just need them to kind of move
closer to me I guess
but I don't know that I I'd want them to
kind of keep their distance because
they're going to shoot me right
so therefore I don't know
um
let's maybe not spawn as many enemies as
quickly so let's do like
at least three seconds between enemies
uh and then let's make them be
so basically a translation
[Music]
plus equals to flower
all right that's not gonna scale
well if we just do
oh well I guess we should normalize this
for it to Vector oh right okay
um yeah so now that's that's fine
[Music]
so if we just that's going to be too too
quick
oh man this is gonna be scary
if it works
uh because I don't know when they
reached the planet
[Music]
I actually don't know if this is two
this is yeah this is away from player
it's just it needs to be that for the
rotation
right so if I make this
what I yeah because yeah because that's
the head of the vector the first one
so I think maybe we just do minus two
player here but then this is this
um if we hit play
yep oh my gosh go away
look at this oh man
luckily I'm quicker than them but like
on of course they don't flock yeah
flocking would be good
because they're onto oh well actually
maybe we don't need that maybe we just
give them Collision
because at the moment I don't think they
collide with each other
I don't know why they don't
[Music]
uh
uh they don't
box Collider
that they probably should
maybe it's just because they're not
being uh their translations being said
and it's bypassing through this engine
is that really
because I feel like it should be or
maybe I should just say it's a dynamic I
mean they probably should be dynamic
anyway but let's see if this makes any
difference
like his NFL bump into each other or not
they're bumping into me so yeah they
should probably bump into each other
if I can make them crash
yeah uh yeah okay good
oh and actually man like if I give them
a bigger
like if I want them to keep some space I
could just give them
um a bigger collider right let me just
show you because this light is for all
answers
uh if I just do yeah even these box
colliders that's a bit of a waste
um but anyway if I just make this a
little bit bigger
like as in just in these two axes Maybe
and they'll be a little bit
they'll keep more distance between
themselves
[Music]
yeah so that's the aiming thing and then
you can see we have some enemies there
like in this case they're just chasing
us but
they're all they're kind of fun
and I got the camera
foreign
[Music]
okay yep
I'll take a look at them properly later
[Music]
so I'm gonna try adding mesh colliders
to each of these
sir
see the morning
[Music]
this has love Network multiplayer yet no
not yet can you hold the volume of the
music a bit uh
better I think my mic is a bit no no
it's not bad if I'm close to it it's
okay
[Music]
all right
um
[Music]
so yeah so the shooting mechanic I guess
uh all right
let's make that happen
and that's good because we can have some
picking up those blood particles work as
well maybe
uh okay search
um player play for player all right so
click to shoot of course so let's do
that shooting uh
it's been one adult's time for things
like cooldowns
um all right so
uh if inputs dots
Mouse button down I guess
left
we can do
so we kind of need to do like a physics
raycast I guess cost Ray
I don't really remember how to do this
orange interaction max distance that
kind of stuff all right
uh
direction
is uh
this direction
I mean draw Crosshair kind of does that
maybe we can actually cache some of that
so that we're not quite
reuse like doing this
too many times but
so origen's gonna beat that by the
direction
is just going to be forward
that might be dependent on the gun but
let's just do 10 for now and we'll
probably the direction will shake up a
bit to simulate accuracy
query
[Music]
can't hit
um
[Music]
if hit starts
how do we know if it hit something is
the NC just going to be not null or
something
like that can I do that
let's try this
okay well that worked that was very
quick
um all right well let's we can actually
just be like how why don't we destroy
the entity
uh hit dot St dot destroy
LOL correct
and shoot you boom
until they're really missing
don't think so
all right cool that works that's easy
um
now instead of destroying then let's
push them back a bit so here dot entity
dot get component raise your body
component dots add Force
any Force Mode
impulse
and we're going to do it in the
direction it was shot in which is
Direction
we're gonna do a random amount of force
[Music]
and gas
again depending on the gun it's the
shotgun it'll be a lot more I guess but
less range
floats flight floats um and we'll do
float times so let's set a baseline of
like one
and then that might not be enough and
then times like five or some
so there's our little random Force
[Music]
okay so that's clearly not enough Force
I want you to
why is it it feels a bit weird doesn't
it on the max distance is 10 as well
and that's probably too much for us
foreign
yeah they're like look at that it's like
they they get faster or something
because the thing is that they they
don't like when they get shot
they don't like stop trying to get to
but also why does it feel like the
gravity is just
ah no that stuff shouldn't be it
because I was gonna say it might have
something to do with their their
movement
uh well yeah because for one this is
actually
I don't know if we should we should
probably add this movement as a force
but also I don't think we're allowed to
we shouldn't be controlling y I guess
so
um
like two player
should maybe be X zero two player Z or
something I don't know
because I think if we control why it
might override them falling I'm probably
wrong yeah that doesn't look look at
that why are you like that
foreign
can we just make them like what if we
make them heavier
but then they're gonna not get pushed
back as as much are they
yeah like I can't really push them back
I can keep firing at them
but that that doesn't really seem to
work
quite like I wanted it to
linear drag angle of disable gravity
could make it I mean it's a gun like the
force is pretty high isn't it
that's probably too much
why do they use something oh I guess
they
they yeah that's big it's because the
ground is like not really
they should probably yeah it's tough
because
I think what happens is they hit the
ground
I feel like these tiles might it might
even be better because I don't know if
the tiles will remain flat because I
guess that's a bit boring isn't it but I
guess there will always be a ground
though like I don't think we'll do
slopes
because I was gonna say what
you don't have a crash counter I think
Hazel crashed for me once since I
started streaming
uh the second time around and I've been
live for what like two hours three hours
yeah but yeah
oh wow I got zero magers of this space
apparently
all right
delete something quickly
it's good because OBS tells me how much
disk space I have left
[Music]
it's honestly just like downloads of
dichotomy
and Forest on this account
I just freed up about a gig just
deleting like
yeah so we went with a coffee idea
anyway what was what I was going to say
was that um
what we probably should do is the
clusters of
like we probably shouldn't have we
definitely shouldn't have a collider on
each one of these hexagons especially a
mesh collider like that
um it should just be
um
the way it should just be
uh it should just be
um what are they called uh like we
should just have a plane like basically
over this entire surface that you know
is your Collider
and that would kind of solve some of
these issues
but yeah
thank you
yeah that kind of sucks it's because it
hits like the edge of the
hexagon it's pretty cool there
now obviously there's no feedback when
you shoot which kind of means it sucks
but uh let's spawn some particles
because that's always fun so particle
system dot spawn impact
now I need the actual particle but uh
translation so I guess
I mean if the entities are the same size
like we can just do hit dot entity Dot
translation and then we could like
basically be like Plus
like the direction
[Music]
that's that's a unit vector
yeah which yeah maybe maybe should be
like times point five
but that should be okay and then the
direction is going to be the direction
impulse four slash say 20 no 10 that
might be too much life
five
counts 20 but we will probably make it
random
and then we just need the particle which
we had in a player didn't we
uh let's uh pile
we need to compile so that we can go
into our
player
and
grab that blood particle
and we can bring it back
file all right
okay
look at all that blood that's kind of
cool
I mean it it's very frictionless and
yeah I'll make it so that it doesn't
have Edge outlines
but yeah now they can now they can bleed
that's way too much force though
why does it it blows back so much
that's the impossible
first round and I guess it's also the
fact that it's so
like it should be pretty frictiony I
think blood because it's blood like it's
a liquid
so it should just stick to surfaces
basically immediately so if we go into
our blood particle
uh which makes you already have one of
those insane but if we
change the
well the restitution should be like zero
and the friction should be like one or
something let's just go full on
date
that's not uh
I guess that's not bad
and shoot two enemies at once maybe
now um what we could do for fun is we
could just not
like let's just try and not compositing
the outline I'm just curious like I mean
that's gonna be for everything and one
of the things that I really need to do
is obviously make it so that this um
uh uh this outline effect stays like for
certain things but not for others
but if I just go into the scene renderer
so we can reload shaders and I go to the
scene composite Shader
one thing we could do is just not
composite the outline
so if I just do it false I think that's
zero Meg again
it's because Visual Studio compiles
stuff man like a crash with zero mag
I probably can't even build this can it
wait why am I debugging this oh that's
that's Hazel
yeah okay so that's oh that looks kind
of cool
what if we don't have outlines
I mean I think I like outlines
but it does look kind of cool without
outline so this is without outlines
I just want to see what the blood looks
like
I mean it's not kind of like it doesn't
really look like blood
so there's all my enemies
oh the performance
too many STS
keep spawning because each one of these
is a part is a is an actual entity
a physics body which is not great for
performance
what do you guys think about the
um lack of outline
thing okay I really need to prep some
disk space though jerks aside
I need to prep some disk space
yeah I'm sure I could just go through
like so many things and just delete like
how big it's this four gig of
intermediates
one of my Hazel brushes
let's go through like all of them
okay I've already freed up 15 gig
I'm done
wow people think it's better without
outlines different agitator or not at
all huh
Tim come here you're the art person
so
I turned outlines off and people kind of
liked it more without Airlines
so this is with outlines on
like the particles of the garbage but I
would have I would turn it off for them
as well right and then
um
yeah that's what that outlines
what do you think I think
yeah because the thing is you kind of
maintain the outline here anyway because
these are physically no well yes but
also because they're physically apart
yeah so yeah you could get the AO I
guess inside there and
I guess that and the Shadows I guess as
well
so it kind of it's almost looks like
it's partially outlined but then you
know these guys look a bit different so
I don't know maybe it is kind of cool
without outlines to be honest yeah
someone says I like the outlines
yeah I mean well man you are too Keen
get off me
like what are you doing get away
um all right
I'm probably spawning too many particles
let's not get too crazy
uh and I guess what we should do is we
should also be like hey hit entity dot
as enemy to get it script and then like
take damage
uh you know 50 uh
30.
well
um now enemy
so let's do public
take damage
Maybe
and health
stuff from our print everything private
ends
health
[Music]
I guess we should do it
not here
okay so now we can destroy them
[Music]
we do have a Max
like range or whatever
oh we should do a little muzzle flash
right I mean we don't have a gun at the
moment which kind of sucks but let's do
something like
let's add a gun to the player so if I
duplicate this guy
I call it gun so Tim's gonna make some
guns I think
point
sure handgun Maybe
yeah
[Music]
looks like a full-on rocket launcher
that's the gun guys okay
it's my store and I'm sticking to it but
it is getting a point light now there
was a bug where the renderer was
crazy
with a point line
so I'm gonna make this orangey
we'll make it pretty bright and it's
going to be at the muzzle and then of
course it's going to so that's what it
looks like
why don't I sit on the floor is it
inside just pause for a second
where's my camera oh does it not release
when it's not that's weird anyway
um player player point line what
[Music]
ah it was inside was it inside
I should get why I can't um
ah here pause you can't look at the
camera
that's a bit weird
it keeps turning away from me oh it's
because the radius is Tiny
that's better
what do you guys think of this is this
too much for a muzzle Clash looks kind
of dope I think let me turn off icons
yeah that's pretty nice
I like that
[Music]
I mean that looks a bit weird
again I guess because the radius is just
weird I mean it'll only flash for like a
second or two you know
but
let me turn off icons
[Music]
have a little look
so it's right out the front right yeah
right out the front
radius let's do four meters Maybe
okay
um and so at that point light
it's a gun Point light let's call it
muzzle flash
so let's do
[Music]
I guess we can just do
muzzle Clash
and then we can just be like hey muzzle
flash get component
Point light compartment
uh
lights
so we can just do that
um and then that way when I shoot
if it's ready to shoot
which is here
then if you're actually shooting
then we can do intensity equals
like 10 or whatever we wanted it to be
um and then we can have a cool down
muzzle flash uh
cool down
like honestly point to like 200
milliseconds maybe that's probably two
two long but
basically I kind of I guess update
shooting can handle that if muzzle flash
cool down
radar then
zero
muzzle flash pull down minus equals time
step and if muzzle flash cooldown is now
less than zero because I don't want to
do it all the time
uh then we'll set intensity
to zero
so we have a very brief window here and
we just need to make sure player has its
muzzle Clash set
yo
what is so difficult about this
I mean it's a bit sus that I'm doing
this here but
I feel like that should should have
worked and then you guys didn't really
need this but I just didn't want to
repeatedly be setting it every frame
that's all
that's a bit lame
I guess because it doesn't have shadows
or anything well actually
could
it could be a spotlight
maybe it's just too bright as well
probably too bright
let's set intensity to like um
two or something
[Music]
oh and if you hold it it stays lit
I mean it should also probably just be a
random value that could be cool
the writer still smooth big yeah
Hazel random
farts
uh
plus 0.5
times 2 plus
[Music]
yeah that's I mean that's better just
having it be randomized like that is
nice
I mean this already looks better
I think you can probably shoot too fast
as well what's the cooldown for shooting
didn't I have a pull down for shooting
update shooting Delta time
nope
[Music]
yeah that's not great uh
that'll be based on the weapon
[Music]
so we won't shoot
stop
I mean that almost looks like
the muzzle flash
pull down should be
a little higher
where does this muzzle flash pull down
what does this get set
or it doesn't
[Music]
might want why would this be here
why did I do this oh no that's resetting
it so where does it set the intensity
here oh here right so then it should
also probably set the cooldown
I mean it should be really quite quick
like I don't know
maybe one frame is good
[Music]
what could be cool as well is um
so the radius is a bit High Maybe
I can't
yeah I don't know if I should have a
cooldown
I feel like it looked better when it was
like literally one frame
[Music]
let's not do
the problem is you don't want to like
you can you can set it to be for one
frame specifically
I think that looks a bit better maybe
you'd want it more intense because all
the radius a bit higher because it's
like that and also what I thought would
be cool is if you literally one thing
you could do
so let's actually just start that at
zero um is you could like at the moment
it's just a point line but what we could
do is we could add a mesh to it
we could add a cube to it right I know
freshly important one but just a cube um
and if we scale
that
[Music]
wait what
Instagram there
why did this get reset
what
but that that's weird
[Music]
oh no I see it that's fine oh no let's
um that's very bad that I did that
so if this is my muzzle flash
let's just copy
I guess this because see it has like a
special scale on it to offset that scale
because that's been on uniformly scaled
um but anyway if I add uh what was it a
point line
and paste that in
um all right so it's got a point like
it's got the same point like it used to
yeah
that's all kind of the same let's delete
the muzzle flash
well we couldn't copy the transform I
guess actually but whatever we've got a
new entity now oh that's bad because the
players lost his muscle Flash
because we made it in USC but anyway um
so that should still be the same but the
reason why I've done this is because
um
we're gonna have this guy I don't know
this is a great idea
but my idea was basically to just make a
material
like
for the muzzle flash
and this guy could be the muzzle flash
material and then this is just going to
be like basically some you know emissive
huge kind of material
and this will just appear for like a
second but the point is you're like
it'll literally be a flash
so it looks a bit better and I guess we
maybe would be like
bad
so it's coming out of the gun you know
I mean we could even like I don't know
if a cube is the best thing like we
could make it a cone
maybe that would be better do we have
any other Primitives here
hexagon we've got hexagon no that's the
one I made
it's gonna say
Uh current okay fine let's make a cone
uh
okay that is a weird
cards
well like then the scale is weird
well actually that might suit it
and that's a weird rotation as well
check that out
that's kind of cool
a muzzle flash
uh and then the idea is to
um
so I think we can basically make that
not be a thing
until we shoot right so that's the
muzzle flash
um and it's got a point light as well
so I think what we can do if I remember
correctly because this is a bit dodgy
and Hazel at the moment but I think what
we can do is we can
basically grab
this muzzle flash entity and I think you
have to get the static mesh component
this is a bit dodgy as I mentioned and
then set visible to false and it won't
render
um otherwise it will
I mean that looks like a muzzle flash
now
because I guess you have one frame of
that NC actually being there
I don't know if it translates well to
the Stream
and I mean you could play with the scale
as well I guess you'd want to right so
when you do that
um maybe also
be like
scale equals uh basically the existing
scale
times a random value
but you'd want to maintain the initial
scale because otherwise you could
deviate further and further from it
uh
so we could do
that times floats
like
well I guess times one
well times no times float is fine but as
long as we
do floats like
maybe times points
three
plus point seven verb
no let's do it so how much maybe 0.5
plus 75 so we can go
0.25 like either side of the scale
so I guess that one
give us a different sized oh we crashed
guys
we crashed
uh uh basically of this stream yeah
of course it's in physics Peter's new
physics engine
has proven to be dodgy uh
I kind of why
well look succeeded
access violation
I guess body is probably null or
something
locked up get body and that might be now
or like not correct
weird I guess I'll send Peter this just
he knows what the deal is
um I don't
hopefully I was saving that scene
because I did do quite a little bit of
work on it
yeah it looks like it
I have a pretty good habit of pressing
Ctrl s
it doesn't seem to be crashing anymore
hmm
having a solution
okay so accuracy Maybe
so did we want to have that
line there
can we even
is that does that work in the runtime
because it is a debug rendering line
thing I think it should work though
so 10 meters is how long the ride cost
is
so that's what this kind of shows us
that doesn't look like 10 meters
that can't be 10 meters around
three four five six
don't think that's Timber but it's not
four either
maybe that is 10 meters
that's longer
I guess it's just hard to tell because
of the perspective
but yeah I don't know like that's it's
kind of like a laser side I guess is the
point
two
I could make it stop
I guess that would be that would make
more sense right if we made it stop
uh but for that to work we'd basically
have to cast a ray
I guess every frame is okay
um
I'll just do it twice for now but
you know
is more than once but uh
the whole point of this I guess is just
to see the distance of the hit
because that's gonna be the line length
so line length is going to be math F Min
hit distance or line length
I think that should be okay
that might be weird yeah because the
collider is bigger
right
but we can just offset that
'd be better to be inside probably the
enemy anyway
yeah so see now we can do this
I mean that's a bit weird but
okay I was gonna do the accuracy
um
so the accuracy situation
is that gonna work
so I want the laser to oh I guess and I
guess that would be kind of like recoil
um I probably should not make like this
guy here yeah
this should probably I wish I could hide
this muzzle flash and see but I
literally cannot hide this season
uh
Gun Barrel let's just call it
so this is kind of where I guess this
gun barrel is really where
um
[Music]
that laser thing should come from
so basically that wears a different
render thing
[Music]
it should kind of be and I guess
translation plus yeah so it's kind of
converging to the center which is nice
but Gun Barrel
uh transform the world transform the
translation
yeah so see now we're kind of
that's hilarious
I guess I should try and turn his thing
to go there Ryan
because that's stupid
yeah I don't think
no well well to be fair though you could
doesn't have to be the middle because
it's not first person right
so
let's do that
yeah
now it's offset from the gun and the
reason why is because now we can add
some recoil to the gun
which is going to be a bit uh
I guess we can just make a go like that
all right
so just add a little bit of X rotation
sure
so subtract a bit of X rotation
um all right
so
no we don't have the gun do we've got
everything except the gun
they compile that no
okay
um
let's put the white outline
what does that mean
oh pounding boxes I showed bounding
boxes it's gonna have but cool all right
so
um yeah so that will just do that
rotation okay so then when we fire yeah
we can basically it can be the shot
cooldown that's kind of cool it shows
you how as long as we can fire again why
not
um but when you do fire up uh you'll
have to do gun dots
rotation equals gun well uh yeah equals
new I guess Vector three Gondor rotation
I guess dot X
and then the rest we don't care about so
we can just do YZ but the X will
subtract oh this will be in um
so let's just do 30 degrees maybe well
again it'll be random I guess probably
uh and then we can lurp it back to where
it needs to be or
[Music]
degrees to radians
let's try that um and then we'll do
every frame I guess
gone dot rotation
uh I guess we can just do it to X can't
we
how do we know what x is supposed to be
though
and also if we add 30 degrees like that
I feel like I have a feeling it's not
going to work properly
because it'll be
kind of the whole quintanian problem
thing
unless we explicitly set it to like
if it's exactly 180
and we know we can just set it to like
150 and then we can
animate it back up to 180 yeah
it's costing there
I don't know this will work math
[Music]
so let's say shot cooldown is going to
be 200 milliseconds we kind of know that
though
so we could just do
um
times five I guess to get it up to one
I've been not available
[Music]
um let's just set it equal to a flat 150
or like yeah
um and then we can live down to like
180.
from the current area
nah this is a bit a bit weird but
it is what it is
why are you annoying
do I have an extra parenthesis or
something
yeah
what am I missing
this is the lab right and that's the X
or is this is that it's not a
Constructor that takes that in for some
weird reason
yeah okay that wasn't a construction I
don't think it's gonna work
oh it actually does work
it's just not attached anymore
what
what the heck why not
setting the rotation just completely
just like doesn't makes it not attached
anymore
yeah look it's attached
but then if you set the right is that
because it's like a physics it is a
physics go away everything's a physics
object these days
okay
I did it
and it's cool because it moves the thing
okay so we got like some shooting going
on now just nice
hmm
you can just hold it as well
I guess you'll have finite ammo though
I guess the gun force is not where it
should be but this now it's not really
the time to balance that
um
to the force
I think the enemies are just too heavy
leave the edge
that this will never last
so soothing that I forget that this
thing is confusing
having such a blast
sorry
it'd be nice if it also I guess added
some angular
like
something you know can I do that
there's also out of faucet location it
could be at the location of the hit that
might be interesting
that would be cool
let's try that so we'll do ad Force at
location and it should like it should
probably know where it got here right
so hit position
um location hit or position
maybe let's make it now that I've made
the enemies lighter let's go back to
this
that yeah that's a bit
but yeah the
the weirdness is like again the physics
is a bit weird because of the
um
the way everything is ah
yeah if I did just make like a
basically I'm like I was thinking if I
just make an empty end like if I just
make let's just show the physics
colliders
um if I just do this basically and then
I add a like box glider to it
and I obviously make it like you know
huge
so there it is
um and then I don't know I could like
make sure that it's kind of above the
hexagons
which I don't know if it would be
then it shouldn't really
shoot these guys is that because it's
hitting my collider but the collider's
below the hexagons at the moment right
yeah it is
where am I heading then
well no that worked
they just don't seem to
oh I'm not hitting them above them
that's why okay but anyway uh so if we
take this
and if we
this is it right
like 0.9 or something I don't know
no they still go up
but also it's probably because they're
weird restitution is too high
um
where's an enemy
or at least
yeah restitution
of friction
but then also I guess the planes
restitution needs to be lower
friction needs to be high Maybe
throws like full on ice skating
yeah like I don't know man the physics
is super weird
like Peter was saying he likes this new
physics engine but
I'm seeing weirdness
he needs to play with the physics when
he wakes up
huh
all right well I might have a Tim Tam
now to reward myself and then I'll
probably
go to sleep
why work too hard you know
and then I'll be back in the morning but
for now I want to get a Tim Tam
there it is
the Tim Tam that I deserve
um
Petra's just having fun with ragdolls
yeah
bro these guys are kin
Yeah Tim is streaming if you guys go to
studiochannel.com you can see
um
everyone's stream on the same page
that was a nice team time
taking a while to clean up all these
they should kind of be shooting at me
though
I should have cover
wouldn't it be nice to have like some
kind of
walls because otherwise it's very flat
all right
foreign
at an angle
I mean like if the face was down to here
this
but
I'm an advertisement
okay so what did I do with this like
where were they supposed to be here
where's the other wall
that's only two
are the other one's probably too low
I kind of thought they'd be
I think it's bigger
ah do I just sucker pathfinding
but yeah jumping would be cool and then
being able to hide well
Ah that's right that player spawns this
totally forgot about this
it's funny
spacebar does that because that was like
the bladder face I first did
yeah and I guess ah
what can I go through
why can't I go through that oh because
I'm not a physics person
kind of
the movement I think is not physics
based
Maybe
um
[Music]
yeah I don't know
is there a limit to how fast you can
spin the view camera around not really
like pretty quick
like obviously you can play with the
sensitivity as well
thank you
um all right so
foreign
there's another crash and guys where is
it which system is it in say it with me
it's in the physics system
you know who wrote a really solid
renderer turns out apart from one typo
which crashed everything
because I accidentally met a typo
ah well click come and look
this will be embarrassing they don't
work but I'm pretty sure they work
uh how do I even approve this let's
call Shadows onto it
Okay so
no that's my Spotlight yeah that's the
point line
uh wait no no pointless
what do you mean
Point lights
like that they're definitely working
look yeah no no it's not it's not that
they weren't working except that you
know that there was huge those articles
oh that yeah
yeah it doesn't seem to be for me for
some reason even though I have seen it
on my computer but spotlights
um as you can see work and also given
class Shadows
they definitely work oh it's hard to
cast The Shadow yeah yeah they do
yeah there it is
um
there's a range as well
yeah spotlights do seem to work
well the artifacts are fine though
because they're not really that's if you
select it that's like an editor or
anything oh yeah
yeah that was only if you had the entity
selected
but I think it was something to do with
the icon or like
I tried to like draw a selection outline
around the light itself
[Music]
Peter's fault
yeah
I don't know I
the worst thing about this crashes is
that they just haven't randomly during
gameplay
so like I'm very scared because if Peter
doesn't iron these out then we could
ship a game that crashes
which surprisingly we haven't done yet I
don't think like I feel like our games
either work
or they just don't open like it's one of
the other there's no like oh it crashed
during
so Peter
yeah Peter it looks like Peter's gonna
have to polish up the physics engine but
good thing is this is all kind of
recorded and
uh you know Peter can investigate what I
did to close the crash or whatever the
call Stacked more closely because I
don't care but yeah
um
so yeah I mean
I don't know I
feel like I am done at this point I'm
just wasting time let's probably go to
bed
um yeah I don't know what the game is
exactly like as in I do have an idea but
there's I mean this is like to be fair
it's been 12 hours since it started and
we're doing a 72 hour one
like there is a lot of time until
Tuesday morning for us
so I feel like this is not bad this is
not a bad start it's like it's like it's
due tomorrow is what I'm feeling
um
raise some of the tiles randomly yeah
that could be cool let me just try that
before I leave
um
because I want to see what that looks
like but yeah that would look cool I
think
um
little generator
no it's called dummy the file because
that was the one Peter committed
um
yeah so that's the why
so I guess we can do
well we could make them all be
at different heights basically
meter
so that's what this would look like whoa
I mean that does look more interesting
but at the moment it doesn't really care
about the physics though but
that looks kind of dark Tim come check
this out
look I raised the heights differently
this could be something you know because
suddenly you have more challenging
terrain to kind of go yeah
yeah because oh hello
and look I clicked again and it crashed
in the physics engine
I think this yeah this is one that's
happened before
Berlin knows yeah but we're gonna use
some kind of
noise
um but like to be honest I kind of like
the chaotic nature of not using noise
but just random because like I mean that
looked cool
because like you know picture and I
literally can't click man
because I guess you know why it's
because it's hitting
oh I know why but Peter should have
protected against this it's because my
array is hitting a static
it's hitting the terrain and it's trying
to apply an Impulse to it because the
gun the gunge the gun ray cost is
hitting
yeah it's just doing it to whatever
entity it hits
but like you know that shouldn't crash
the engine
yeah okay I won't shoot them
but like what I'm saying is like imagine
if like you obviously you can't just
step onto this one we could have the
character because you want to use
xerox's character controller the
character control can automatically Step
Up on Ledges right but if it's too high
like this one
I guess I'll show a stream like this one
you have to do some Parkour you'll have
to jump onto it but my point is that
might be fun with coffee but what's also
really cool about this terrain is that
it lets you seek cover from enemies
because if
well yeah but they're gonna like at the
moment they're just going right towards
you but my plan is to
make them try and shoot you you know
because they're gonna they're not gonna
no
no we're not gonna have that but
like you know it might be cool to
use that kind of terrain to uh to your
advantage but of course you could you
could like feel the noise would be nice
because
uh it would be it'll let us control it
obviously a lot more
like he's gonna be somewhere at a valid
spot on the map as well
larger hexagons that's also I guess a
possibility
um
because like oh because you made them
I've already
that's all right though
now this size I think is cool
um but to be honest yeah I really
wouldn't change
look at that that's kind of cool just
seeing them like Rush at you from the
distance
clicked
how dare I click
thank you Peter although it is my code
kind of my C sharp card that's causing
that but
I don't know I think that that would be
kind of cool like this itself makes it
just look really cool
and I can't like these colors just
remind me of like Google or something
oh and like we could introduce the fog
that we had in um
Forest not the weird transparency Shadow
effect but the fog because I guess that
would
wait let me look I don't even know what
that is though that's a Shader so it's
not in the game but
yeah I don't know I think that's cool
though it's a good idea to kind of raise
this
because it means that it looks like this
uh the blue hexagon is not specular
effective no I'm I the hexagons have
different roughnesses
uh and I just made the warm tones
reflective because I because just
because it looks cool
so the blue and green ones as you can
see like with the specular highlight
here there are not I don't know that's
my um
drawing thing uh they're not reflective
but then these guys are I I don't know
if it looks that necessarily that cool
when it's like this
but when it's um
like if you
had them all flat I think it is a cool
effect
because when it's all flat you kind of
get like the specular highlight as you
can see kind of there's like some matte
turns and some specular ones and it just
makes it look a bit more interesting
kind of like tiles
so that's what I did yeah
oh and also the other thing we could
turn on which I haven't really been
turning on for this is um
we could also have
screen space Reflections on
if you're on over reflective tiles
then you'd see like it's a little hard
to say but you can see the the
reflection
of certain things
I mean it's pretty obvious like for this
Ah that's half resolution you can make
it full resolution
so it looks nicer you can kind of see
the reflection
it's like a shadow and there's a
there's a shadow and there's a
reflection
but it's not very distinct so the
reflection kind of looks like the
shatter
and that won't happen over
that'll only happen over things with an
appropriate level of reference or
whatever but yeah all right cool all
right I'm gonna go
um
thank you guys for watching the stream
I'll be back
soon ish
maybe well no not that soon um
I'll try and be back in like 10 to 12
hours maybe a bit less hopefully
um but yeah
uh
uh you guys can go watch Tim I can't
raid
uh because YouTube doesn't support that
but what I can do is send your link to
Tim's stream
so I want to do that
can go and raid Tim
because he's
substance painting
uh
the character
so yeah
now YouTube does support raids really
how do I ride Tim
I don't see a bright button anywhere
do I have to do like slash right or
something cryptic
but he has to allow you to raid him
I don't know this is too difficult
though
like
I'm not gonna do that
you guys can just go
and look Tim apparently has zero crashes
but it is sponsored by Hazel so who
knows
all right thank you guys see you next
time goodbye